[Music]
there are 50 to 60 armed men and women
standing on the pitch
you tapped in good copy it's okay
we are you 30 years
in the future it's okay sweetie we are
fighting a war
our enemy is not human and we are losing
in 11 months time all human beings in
the future will be wiped from the face
of the earth
unless you help us
well they say kids never come by unless
they need something
dad i need your help i'll get my coat 30
years
in the future we are fighting a war
our enemy is not human and we are losing
we need you to fight
i will be back and i love you chickpea
seven days from now when you're sent
into that war
you won't be fighting for your country
you'll be fighting for the world is it
all right
yeah going to war stop talking listen
sorry i mean when i'm nervous i talk i'm
like 97 on the nervous scale
that should be fun
welcome to the future you and your unit
are now
in 2051.
they're everywhere we are food and they
are hungry
our enemy is smarter
faster and stronger
than you can possibly imagine
do you want to see something really
dangerous i feel like literally that's
all i've been doing since i got here but
okay
within the next few weeks the human
species won't disappear from the base of
the earth
nothing we do here matters that's where
you're wrong
i don't believe that one bit together we
can stop this war
from ever happening this is my
opportunity to give this world a second
chance
second chances are really hard to come
by
i'm not gonna hide
i'm gonna fight it's not even loaded
yeah well yeah it's not loaded it's a
pressurized cabin why would i load it
in the cabin the boat goes in thing and
everybody sucked out
[Music]
you